Katrina: 好烦
Katrina: So annoying
Katrina: 等我找到了男朋友我羞辱你
Katrina: Just wait till I find a boyfriend, I'll humiliate you
Shure的女友:我帮掐死他吧
Shure's GF: Let me strangle him
Katrina: 等我找到了男朋友发他几张
Katrina: Just wait till I find a boyfriend, I'll send him some pics
Shure: 确实 这个很好拿下
Shure: Indeed, this is easy to handle
Shure: 对啊哈哈哈对
Shure: Yeah, hahaha, yes
Katrina: 他喜欢我
Katrina: He likes me
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Katrina: 我不知道
Katrina: I don't know
Shure: 我们在给他感情
Shure: We're giving him emotions
Shure的女友:当机了
Shure's GF: It's frozen.
Shure: 当机了
Shure: It's frozen.
Shure的女友:是感情当机了
Shure's GF: It's an emotional freeze.
Shure: 怎么带东北口音了
Shure: Why do you have a northeastern accent?
Shure: 你这个
Shure: What's up with that?
Shure的女友:没有啊
Shure's GF: No, I don't.
Shure: Alright来暂停一下
Shure: Alright, let's pause for a moment.
Shure: 我们去楼下开个香槟
Shure: Let's go downstairs and pop some champagne.
Shure: 好吧 哇 S S
Shure: Okay, wow, S S.
Shure: 有点东西的
Shure: There's something about this.
Shure: 来来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure: 去去楼下把这香槟开一下
Shure: Let's go downstairs and open the champagne.
Shure: 哎哎别别别
Shure: Hey, hey, no, no.
Shure: 对着那个麦克风关了
Shure: Turn off the microphone first.
Shure: 你你你回来你回来
Shure: You, you, you, come back.
Shure: 回来再倒
Shure: Come back and then pour.
Shure: 来来来开香槟去
Shure: Come on, let's open the champagne.
Jack: 或有一些新八卦
Jack: There might be some new gossip.
Shure的女友:我我我那天跟你打视频的时候
Shure's GF: The other day when we were video chatting,
Shure的女友:是不是听到了一些我不该听的东西
Shure's GF: Did I hear something I shouldn't have heard?
Katrina: 是不是这边那个男生
Katrina: Was it that guy over there?
Shure的女友:是不是跟那个男生没有八卦啊
Shure's GF: Was there no gossip with that guy?
Shure: 啊是另一个来着
Shure: Oh, it was another guy.
Shure的女友:是另一个男生啊
Shure's GF: It was another guy?
男嘉宾:我问你我问你我问你
Male Guest: Let me ask you, let me ask you.
男嘉宾:你为什么要选他
Male Guest: Why did you choose him?
男嘉宾:因为北京就他一个认识的OK
Male Guest: Because he's the only one I know in Beijing, okay?
男嘉宾:他为什么来
Male Guest: Why did he come?
男嘉宾:他来了不是他有空他就要来
Male Guest: He came because he was free, he had to come.
男嘉宾:有空就要来了
Male Guest: If he was free, he had to come.
Nicous: 从男生的视角里
Nicous: From a guy's perspective,
男嘉宾:刘宇轩只邀请了我一个男人
Male Guest: Liu Yuxuan only invited me, a guy.
Nicous: 从男人视角里就是刘宇轩居然来到这
Nicous: From a guy's perspective, Liu Yuxuan actually came here.
Nicous: 只邀请了我
Nicous: And only invited me.
Nicous: 而且别的人
Nicous: And other people...
男嘉宾:只有我们
Male Guest: Only us...
男嘉宾:别的人也喊了女朋友
Male Guest: Other people also brought their girlfriends.
男嘉宾:而且别人带的女朋友啊
Male Guest: And the girlfriends they brought...
Shure的女友:你所有报价他会给你加一
Shure's GF: He'll add one to all your offers.
Shure: 诸位
Shure: Everyone...
Shure的女友:对不不
Shure's GF: No, no
Shure的女友:你不需要
Shure's GF: You don't need
Shure的女友:你不需要再爆炸了
Shure's GF: You don't need to explode again
Shure: 对啊这都是我们的哎呀
Shure: Yeah, this is all ours, oh my
Katrina: 那他为什么老要加一个
Katrina: Then why does he always have to add one
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh my
Shure: 来来开开香槟再下来
Shure: Come on, let's pop the champagne and then come down
Shure: 开香槟再回来
Shure: Pop the champagne and come back
Shure: 来
Shure: Come
Shure的女友:我不知道我走了
Shure's GF: I don't know, I'm leaving
Shure: 小心台阶小心台阶小心台阶
Shure: Watch your step, watch your step, watch your step
Shure的女友:你小心好
Shure's GF: You be careful, okay
Shure: 好好
Shure: Okay, okay
Shure的女友:我自己走我的啊
Shure's GF: I'll walk by myself
Shure: OK你别趴冲了再给我冲倒就行
Shure: OK, don't rush and knock me over
Alice:你说啥来着
Alice: What did you say
Shure的女友:你摔了你老贵
Shure's GF: If you fall, it'll be expensive
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right
Shure: 杨老板呢 杨老板
Shure: Where's Jake? Jake
Shure: 杨老板在外头好像 来吧
Shure: Jake's outside, I think. Come on
Shure: 来快快快
Shure: Come on, quick, quick, quick
Lucia:你看
Lucia: Look
Shure: 下来下来下来
Shure: Come down, come down, come down
Tasha:怎么又下来了都
Tasha: Why is everyone coming down again
Jake:想不起来
Jake: Can't remember
Jake:过两分钟就想起来了
Jake: I'll remember in two minutes
女嘉宾:下来开香槟
Female Guest: Come down to pop the champagne
Tasha:下来
Tasha: Come down
Lucia:要是过两分钟也想不起来那就
Lucia: If you can't remember in two minutes, then...
Tasha:开完香槟然后就结束了吗
Tasha: After we pop the champagne, is it over?
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh
Tasha:还是继续是吧
Tasha: Or do we continue?
Shure的女友:应该没有吧
Shure's GF: Probably not, right?
Shure: 随便随便都可以
Shure: Whatever, whatever, it's all good
Tasha:那去楼上开香槟那为啥不
Tasha: Then why not pop the champagne upstairs
Shure: 因为这个东西看完咱们要脱呀
Shure: Because after we watch this, we need to take it off
Shure: 它会崩的一课地都是 你知道吧
Shure: It will explode everywhere, you know
Shure的女友:你你你把那个铁丝拧开的时候
Shure's GF: When you twist the wire...
Shure的女友:你手在这里压一下
Shure's GF: Press your hand here.
Shure的女友:他不会太绷
Shure's GF: It won't be too tight.
Shure的女友:你把他所有气放完
Shure's GF: Let all the air out.
Shure的女友:我我我我我怕手折
Shure's GF: I'm, I'm, I'm afraid my hand might break.
Shure的女友:来吧来吧
Shure's GF: Come on, come on.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Shure: 该把这也开了吧
Shure: Should we open this too?
Shure: 我把他们都叫下来
Shure: I'll call them all down.
Shure: 然后咱开一个
Shure: Then we'll start one.
Shure: ego life圆满收官
Shure: Ego life, a perfect ending.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay?
Shure: 快快快快下来下来下来下来来
Shure: Quick, quick, quick, come down, come down, come down.
Nicous: 全是哥们
Nicous: They're all buddies.
Nicous: 就他就他一个不是哥们
Nicous: Except him, he's not a buddy.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: It's over.
刘婷:干啥
Liu Ting: What are you doing?
Nicous: 你是不是邀请他了
Nicous: Did you invite him?
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声哈哈哈
Lucia: Wrapping up the finale, hahaha.
男嘉宾:你是不是跟他一个人过来的
Male Guest: Did you come with him?
Katrina: 因为我就北京就他一个熟一点的
Katrina: Because he's the only one I know well in Beijing.
男嘉宾:那你今天下午不是跟他坐在这
Male Guest: Didn't you sit with him this afternoon?
男嘉宾:跟他一直坐
Male Guest: Sit with him the whole time.
Katrina: 因为我坐在他们俩
Katrina: Because I was sitting between them.
男嘉宾:这个男人同学说
Male Guest: That guy said...
Shure: 瞅瞅说什么说什么
Shure: Look, look, what are they saying?
Shure: 是不是偷偷说我坏话了
Shure: Are they secretly talking bad about me?
Shure的女友:没有我说接孩子放学啊
Shure's GF: No, I was talking about picking up the kids from school.
Shure的女友:接孩子刚才那些啊
Shure's GF: Picking up the kids, just now.
Shure: 走吧走吧
Shure: Let's go, let's go.
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Shure: 院院里
Shure: In the yard.
Shure: 把香槟开了就完事了
Shure: Just pop the champagne and we're done.
Nicous: 竟然看不出来那男的喜欢她了
Nicous: Didn't you see that guy likes her?
Jake:耶 到点了
Jake: Yay, it's time.
男嘉宾:你觉得
Male Guest: Do you think...
男嘉宾:你觉得今天下午可以邀请来那个
Male Guest: Do you think we can invite him this afternoon?
男嘉宾:用刀开
Male Guest: Use a knife to open it.
Shure: 不用不用不用
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 来 杨老板 没你不行
Shure: Come on, Jake, we can't do it without you.
Lucia:其实我们第二天又会买买买然后就是
Lucia: Actually, the next day we'll go shopping again and then...
Shure: 啊哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 把这开完
Shure: Let’s finish this up.
男嘉宾:看到没有牛逼看到没有
Male guest: See that? Isn’t that awesome? See that?
Alice:然后第二天把冰箱里的 不是
Alice: And then the next day, the stuff in the fridge, no...
男嘉宾:一句话
Male guest: One sentence.
Katrina: 不可以邀请朋友过来就朋友
Katrina: You can't invite friends over, just friends...
Nicous: 我他妈喊了一万个人
Nicous: I invited like ten thousand people.
Nicous: 你看有人吗
Nicous: Do you see anyone?
Nicous: 哈哈哈但但你只要求
Nicous: Hahaha, but you only require...
Nicous: 通州啊通州啊
Nicous: Tongzhou, Tongzhou!
Lucia:但是一点新的光吃新的就够
Lucia: But just some new food is enough.
Nicous: 来回
Nicous: Back and forth.
男嘉宾:通州很远
Male guest: Tongzhou is far.
男嘉宾:他在清华跟我们来的距离是一样的
Male guest: The distance from Tsinghua to here is the same.
Nicous: 太远了 我草
Nicous: Too far, damn.
男嘉宾:哈哈哈巨远
Male guest: Hahaha, super far.
Katrina: 有点想死
Katrina: I feel like dying a bit.
Nicous: 采访一下
Nicous: Let's have an interview.
Nicous: 你觉得那个男生喜欢他吗
Nicous: Do you think that guy likes him?
Jack: 婧康有女朋友他应该能感受出来
Jack: Jingkang has a girlfriend, he should feel it.
女嘉宾:谁有女朋友啊
Female guest: Who has a girlfriend?
女嘉宾:你有女朋友啊
Female guest: You have a girlfriend?
Lucia:你们是舍友还是
Lucia: Are you roommates or...
Jake:以前有过
Jake: Used to.
Jake:以前有现在没有
Jake: Used to, not anymore.
Nicous: 不好意思哎我不是故意的
Nicous: Sorry, I didn't mean to.
Shure: 哈哈哈 来来来
Shure: Hahaha, come on, come on.
Nicous: 我操
Nicous: Damn.
Shure: 来来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Nicous: 完了我靠完了
Nicous: It's over, damn, it's over.
Shure: 康康神咱们先把香槟开了
Shure: Kang, let's open the champagne first.
Jake:好好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Nicous: 卧槽卧槽
Nicous: Whoa, whoa.
Nicous: 完了卧槽
Nicous: It's over, whoa.
Tasha:提起了人家的伤心史
Tasha: You brought up their sad past.
Jack: 节约人品你同等开一个是一个
Jack: Save your luck, opening one is one less.
Nicous: 卧槽卧槽
Nicous: Whoa, whoa.
Jake:我我我觉
Jake: I, I, I think...
Jake:得也有 哈哈哈
Jake: Got it, hahaha.
Shure: 来来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure: 一起一起来
Shure: Let's do it together.
Shure: come om
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 小心崩到你的电脑哦
Shure: Be careful not to spill on your computer.
Jake: 好嘞 我们先开香槟
Jake: Alright, let's pop the champagne first.
Alice:让我来录一下
Alice: Let me record this.
Lucia:我开玩笑的
Lucia: I'm just kidding.
Alice:321 哎
Alice: 3, 2, 1... hey!
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Alice:让大家都出来
Alice: Let everyone join in.
Alice:9点了
Alice: It's 9 o'clock.
Shure: 他是不是偷偷说我坏话呢
Shure: Is he secretly talking bad about me?
Shure的女友:某种意义上
Shure's GF: In a way.
Shure的女友:其实我不太在意你们两个人什么关系
Shure's GF: Honestly, I don't really care about your relationship.
Shure的女友:啊但是他的视线就是占比
Shure's GF: But his gaze is quite dominating.
Shure的女友:大概是
Shure's GF: Probably.
Shure: 直接开始就行
Shure: Let's just start.
Shure的女友:往往往然后往大家那里视线扫两眼
Shure's GF: Often, he glances at everyone briefly.
Shure的女友:然后剩下的时间都在你这
Shure's GF: Then spends the rest of the time looking at you.
Jack: 这可是非常骗不了人的
Jack: That's really hard to fake.
Katrina: 啊真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure: 就应该把这个眼球追踪都给他追踪到
Shure: We should track his eye movements.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Katrina: 我只觉得有点奇怪的是
Katrina: What I find strange is...
Katrina: 他为啥老让他给我俩拍合照
Katrina: Why does he always want to take photos with us?
Katrina: 他给我俩拍合照
Katrina: He takes photos with us.
Katrina: 明明我们一直在拍情侣
Katrina: Even though we're always taking couple pictures.
Katrina: 他非要就一直跟我俩拍照
Katrina: He insists on taking photos with us.
Nicous: 好孺子不可教也
Nicous: A good student can't be taught.
Shure: 不不不咱咱先把香槟开了回
Shure: No, no, let's pop the champagne first.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Nicous: 其实我觉得你邀请他过来就是那意思
Nicous: I think you invited him for that reason.
Nicous: 因为你俩
Nicous: Because you two...
Jack: 就你邀请的人家
Jack: The person you invited...
Jack: 难道不是
Jack: Isn't it?
Nicous: 就是
Nicous: Exactly.
Katrina: 我看过很多玩的很好的男生朋友
Katrina: I've seen many male friends who get along well.
Katrina: 很好的男生朋友
Katrina: Good male friends.
Katrina: 我摇一个怎么讲
Katrina: Let me explain...
Katrina: 就是因为他在场内啊
Katrina: Just because he is inside.
Shure: 因为他在北京
Shure: Because he is in Beijing.
Nicous: 不 在他就觉得
Nicous: No, he just feels like...
Nicous: 昂勒密
Nicous: Anlamy.
Shure: 不 我们我们先开
Shure: No, let's start first.
Shure: 开了他边喝边聊行不行
Shure: Start it, he can drink and chat at the same time, right?
Alice:还是选了这个香肠的
Alice: Still chose this sausage one.
Jake:边喝边聊
Jake: Drink and chat.
Nicous: 听我说你
Nicous: Listen to me, you...
Nicous: 有人说是这样的
Nicous: Someone said it like this.
Jake:边喝边聊边喝走走走
Jake: Drink and chat, drink, let's go, let's go.
Shure: 哎呀哎呀 边喝边
Shure: Oh yeah, drink and...
Shure: 他他这个他这个
Shure: He, he, this, this...
Shure: 葡萄倒了快他妈1,000下了已经
Shure: The grapes are already poured out, almost a thousand already.
Nicous: 哎听我说这样的
Nicous: Hey, listen to me, it's like this...
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Jack: 有没有一种可能敬请期待
Jack: Is there a possibility, stay tuned.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Ouch.
Jack: 这个这个事情很显然啊
Jack: This, this matter is very obvious.
Jack: 这个事就是很
Jack: This matter is just...
Nicous: 就是现在那个男生一定觉得
Nicous: Right now that guy must feel...
Nicous: 如果你后面还跟他去正常联系
Nicous: If you keep in touch with him normally...
Nicous: 他就会觉得这个人怎么一直吊着
Nicous: He will feel like why is this person always dragging it out.
Nicous: 有没有一种可能
Nicous: Is there a possibility...
Nicous: 你觉得那些好兄弟都不喜欢你
Nicous: You feel like those good brothers don't like you.
Nicous: 所以你觉得无所谓
Nicous: So you feel it doesn't matter.
Jack: 对啊或他们就他们觉得对啊但是
Jack: Yeah, or they just, they feel like yeah but...
Nicous: 正好这个男的喜欢就一样了
Nicous: Just so happens that guy likes it, so it's the same.
Katrina: 所以他觉得在他的视角
Katrina: So he feels from his perspective...
Katrina: 我邀请他就代表我喜欢他
Katrina: Inviting him means I like him.
Nicous: 对而且而且
Nicous: Right, and also...
Nicous: 重点问题是我今天下午才坐到你旁边
Nicous: The key issue is I just sat next to you this afternoon.
Nicous: 你们俩就那样
Nicous: And you two were like that...
Nicous: 硬坐了一下午
Nicous: Sat there awkwardly all afternoon.
Nicous: 对啊哈哈哈
Nicous: Yeah, haha.
Katrina: 他都坐过来了我能跑吗
Katrina: He already sat over here, can I run away?
Nicous: 那你应该喊那你应该喊一个董超超
Nicous: Then you should call, you should call Jack.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jack: 你没看我当时不往那坐吗
Jack: Didn't you see I didn't sit there?
Katrina: 坐我俩中间吗
Katrina: Sitting between us?
Jack: 我当时都走了呀
Jack: I already left at that time.
Jack: 我本来坐在这
Jack: I was originally sitting here.
Katrina: 你怎么一言不发就开呢
Katrina: Why did you start without saying anything?
Katrina: 就开呢还没录呢
Katrina: Started without recording.
Nicous: 对啊
Nicous: Yeah.
男嘉宾:我给你塞回去
Male Guest: I'll put it back for you.
男嘉宾:你重新再开一遍
Male Guest: You start it again.
Jack: 你再开一回吧
Jack: Start it again.
Shure: 我真
Shure: I really...
Jack: 没摇吧
Jack: Didn't shake it, right?
Lucia:塞回去气不够了
Lucia: Putting it back won't have enough air.
Shure: 我摇了我真摇了
Shure: I shook it, I really did.
Jack: 多摇点再来一回再
Jack: Shake it more and try again.
Shure: 在
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 再来一条
Shure: Let's try another one.
Shure: 这玩意怎么塞回去啊 哥
Shure: How do you put this thing back? Bro...
Jake:他 他是
Jake: He, he is...
Shure: 哎是那天这个还有个塞
Shure: Oh, that day there was another one to put back.
Jake:哎呀 我草
Jake: Oh my, damn it.
Shure: 我把还有几个
Shure: I have a few more.
Katrina: 就是男女对唱
Katrina: It's a male and female duet.
Katrina: 他非要我看他的眼睛
Katrina: He insisted I look into his eyes.
Shure: 嘬一口吧
Shure: Take a sip.
Nicous: 因为如果因为如果他真的很
Nicous: Because if, because if he really...
Shure: 真的懒得刷了拿纸杯吧
Shure: I'm really too lazy to wash it, let's use a paper cup.
Shure: 拿纸杯吧
Shure: Use a paper cup.
Shure: 可以用纸杯了吗
Shure: Can we use a paper cup now?
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure: 走了
Shure: Let's go.
Jack: 走掉了
Jack: Left.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No...
Shure的女友:他真的有
Shure's GF: He really has...
Shure的女友:就是他整个人注意力都在
Shure's GF: All his attention is on...
Nicous: 不是你哦
Nicous: Not you, okay?
Jack: 就是这个点
Jack: It's just this point.
Nicous: 你找男生
Nicous: You're looking for a guy.
Katrina: 他没有普通朋友
Katrina: He doesn't have ordinary friends.
Shure的女友:就那天
Shure's GF: That day
Nicous: 没出的问题
Nicous: No problems occurred
Lucia:我也没吃上啊
Lucia: I didn't get to eat either
Nicous: 是他出问题
Nicous: It was his problem
Lucia:咱们不是在这外边耍
Lucia: Weren't we just playing outside?
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake
Jake:来
Jake: Come on
Shure: ego life
Shure: Ego life
Jake:哎大卖大卖
Jake: Hey, big sales, big sales
Shure: 大卖了
Shure: Big sales
Shure: 圆满结束了
Shure: It's a wrap
Shure: 基本上
Shure: Basically
Shure: 他在开车呢
Shure: He's driving
Nicous: 解说是
Nicous: The commentary is
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thank you
Lucia: 谁要开车
Lucia: Who's driving?
Lucia:你要开车啊
Lucia: Are you driving?
Alice:嗯干嘛
Alice: Hmm, what's up?
Jake:那你喝点橙汁吧
Jake: Then have some orange juice
女嘉宾:可惜了啊
Female Guest: What a pity
Jake:要不
Jake: Otherwise
Nicous: 没事没事
Nicous: It's okay, it's okay
Nicous: 我不喝
Nicous: I won't drink
Jake:你喝点桃汁吧
Jake: Have some peach juice
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Jake:白水啊
Jake: Plain water then
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks
Alice:破 破戒了
Alice: Breaking the rule
Alice:农夫微醺水
Alice: Farmer's slightly drunk water
Shure: 还有还有谁 来点吧
Shure: Anyone else? Have some
Jake:哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Haha, alright, alright
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 来点吧路亚
Shure: Have some, Lucia
Jake:嗯好的
Jake: Okay
Lucia:啊 好的
Lucia: Ah, alright
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Shure: 客气
Shure: You're welcome
Shure的女友:觉得啊这个人好像对我有意思
Shure's GF: Feels like this person is interested in me
Shure的女友:那种男生你都可以归为
Shure's GF: You can categorize those kinds of guys
Lucia:哇好多泡泡
Lucia: Wow, so many bubbles
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice:这多少度啊
Alice: What's the alcohol percentage?
Nicous: 喝出了粮食酒的感觉
Nicous: Tastes like grain alcohol.
Lucia:气泡酒可能一般11-15左右
Lucia: Sparkling wine is usually around 11-15%.
Shure: 11
Shure: 11.
Alice:这么辣吗
Alice: Is it that strong?
Alice:我现在口味这么淡吗
Alice: Is my taste this mild now?
Shure: 11.5对 不它
Shure: 11.5, right? No, it...
Alice:才十来度
Alice: Only about ten degrees.
Jake:来来敬敬敬
Jake: Come on, cheers, cheers, cheers!
女嘉宾:怎么
Female Guest: What?
Jake:你的好朋友来
Jake: Your good friend is here.
Alice:感觉我退化了吗
Alice: Am I regressing?
Shure: 来一杯
Shure: Have a drink.
Alice:可能吧我已经很久不喝酒了哦
Alice: Maybe, I haven't had a drink in a long time.
Alice:你倒点吧
Alice: Pour a little.
Nicous: 我不要
Nicous: I don't want any.
Jack: 我晚上开车呢
Jack: I'm driving tonight.
Alice:那你拿个这干啥
Alice: Then why did you take it?
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Lucia:一点撤不开
Lucia: Can't open it at all.
Alice:神经
Alice: Nonsense.
Shure: 还有谁没有吗
Shure: Anyone else not have one?
Shure: OK都有了吧
Shure: Okay, everyone has one, right?
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 你你你来一杯吗
Shure: You, you, you want a drink?
女嘉宾:不用不用
Female Guest: No, no.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Alice:我那啥了
Alice: What did I...
Shure: 我们举杯敬
Shure: Let's raise our glasses.
Shure: 敬ego来来先先敬ego life一杯
Shure: To ego, come on, first a toast to ego life.
Shure: 然后再再说这个来
Shure: Then we'll talk about this, come on.
Shure: 哈哈哈来来来ego life哎
Shure: Hahaha, come on, come on, ego life, hey.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yeah!
男嘉宾: 好
Male Guest: Okay.
刘婷:没事还会有还会有
Liuting: No worries, there will be more.
Shure: 谁问的倒吗
Shure: Who asked for a refill?
Lucia:还有还有
Lucia: There's more.
Lucia:没倒完呢
Lucia: Haven't finished pouring yet.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Jake:说到哪了
Jake: Where were we?
Katrina: 我我真的很想知道
Katrina: I really want to know
Katrina: 那他11月份的时候跟我分开
Katrina: So, he broke up with me in November
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks
Katrina: 分开就这样拥抱一下
Katrina: We just hugged when we broke up
Katrina: 我以为是礼节
Katrina: I thought it was a formality
Katrina: 就是有一种意思
Katrina: Like, it meant something
Nicous: 谁跟暧昧拥抱一下
Nicous: Who hugs ambiguously?
Nicous: 不会的不会的
Nicous: No way, no way
Nicous: 绝对不会
Nicous: Definitely not
Jack: 这国内啊
Jack: This is in our country
Katrina: 没有就是就是
Katrina: No, it's just, just...
Katrina: 我感觉这张脸不是啊
Katrina: I feel like this face is not...
Jack: 这国内啊
Jack: This is in our country
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed
Shure的女友:能完成你觉得所有的男生对你啊
Shure: Can you complete it, do you think all guys are like this towards you?
Shure的女友:你觉得OK
Shure: Do you think it's OK?
Shure的女友:他可能有点暧昧
Shure: He might be a bit ambiguous
Shure的女友:你就可以把他归到啊
Shure: You can categorize him as someone who likes you
Shure的女友:他喜欢我这个范围内
Shure: Because
Shure的女友:因为
Jack: 你这还明显
Jack: This is still obvious
Lucia:然后我帮你们都打一下
Lucia: And then I'll help you all with it
Jack: 分开的时候拥抱一下
Jack: Hugging when saying goodbye
Jack: 生病的时候给你买药
Jack: Buying medicine when you're sick
Jack: 今天过去坐你旁边啊
Jack: Sitting next to you today
今Jack: 天今天就是今天
Jack: Today, just today
Jack: 这一天你生病了还给你买药
Jack: This day, you were sick and he bought you medicine
Katrina: 他坐我旁边
Katrina: He sat next to me
Katrina: 好奇怪我都我一个人坐在那
Katrina: It's so strange, I was sitting alone
Katrina: 他非要从凳子上坐过来
Katrina: He insisted on moving from his seat
Jack: 生病给你买药还不奇怪吗
Jack: Buying you medicine when you're sick isn't strange?
女嘉宾:盖死都怪怪
Female Guest: It's weird, totally weird
Shure的女友:这还不能说明问题吗
Shure: Doesn't this explain the problem?
Jack: 对啊盖死的全在凳子上
Jack: Yeah, it's weird, totally weird
Shure: 我天啊 你的
Shure: Oh my god, your...
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yeah
Shure:  AI能分析明白这个吗
Shure: Can AI understand this?
Jake: 我觉得能
Jake: I think it can
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Ouch
Jake:我觉得AI已经能分析明白
Jake: I think AI can already figure it out.
Shure: AI能分清明白你这个是吗
Shure: AI can figure out this, right?
Jake:您这得 它得他得训练训练你
Jake: It needs to be trained, you know.
Jack: 我感觉我们几个毛都已经能推测出来
Jack: I feel like even we can already guess it.
Jake:他得训一训的得训一训
Jake: It needs some training, definitely needs training.
Jack: 到时候我们给它
Jack: Then we'll give it to it.
男嘉宾:从这两个人是什么关系
Male Guest: From these two, what’s their relationship?
男嘉宾:从他的描述来看
Male Guest: Based on his description,
男嘉宾:这两个人很有可能是情侣关系
Male Guest: these two are very likely a couple.
Jack: 嗯对
Jack: Hmm, right.
Jack: 要给派的DVT
Jack: We need to give it a DVT.
Jack: 估计能行啊
Jack: I guess it might work.
Jack: 我我我们来看
Jack: Let's take a look.
Jack: 说到照片
Jack: Speaking of photos,
Jack: 这不有吗
Jack: Here they are.
Jack: 让让大家来介绍一下
Jack: Let's introduce them to everyone.
男嘉宾:来来来搞个
Male Guest: Alright, let's do it.
Jake:唉
Jake: Sigh
Jack: 来大家来照照照片
Jack: Come on, let's take some photos.
Shure: 还要吗
Shure: Do we still need more?
Jack: 哇拍这么多呀拍这么多拍这么多
Jack: Wow, taking so many pictures, so many, so many.
Nicous: 拍这么多可以啊
Nicous: Taking this many is fine.
Katrina: 他让他拍的呀
Katrina: He asked him to take them.
Jack: 我靠他们给他拍太爽了
Jack: Damn, they took so many, that's awesome.
Jake:那确实不用看了
Jake: No need to look anymore, for sure.
Shure: 服根了吧啊
Shure: Satisfied now, huh?
Shure的女友:服根啦
Shure's GF: Satisfied.
Jake:你用文心
Jake: You use Wenxin.
Shure: 没喝够 是吧
Shure: Haven't had enough, right?
Shure: 能回一下吗
Shure: Can you reply?
Jake:哎我看一下啊
Jake: Let me check.
Jack: 这个我感觉
Jack: I feel like
Shure: 我应该回吧
Shure: Should I reply?
Shure: 你你还能回吗
Shure: Can you reply?
Jack: 我来看看我来看看
Jack: Let me take a look, let me take a look.
Shure的女友:时间没问题的话我就没问题
Shure's GF: If the timing is fine, I have no problem.
Jake:这一张好像还
Jake: This one seems fine.
Katrina: 因为当时会觉得他是一个比较
Katrina: Because at that time, I felt he was quite
Jake:你要你要
Jake: You want, you want
Katrina: 唯一的人觉得我俩见一面不容易Katrina: 就想拍照我就这样想
Katrina: The only person who thinks it's hard for us to meet, Katrina: just wants to take a picture. That's how I feel.
Shure: 没有啊
Shure: No, not at all.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:你要多给几张才给查GPT
Jake: You need to take more photos before you get to check GPT.
Shure: 你想
Shure: You think.
Shure的女友:但你
Violet: But you.
Shure的女友:你把你把谢彬竹赶走了
Violet: You drove Xie Binzhu away.
Shure: 谢彬竹本来就没睡我这
Shure: Xie Binzhu wasn't sleeping at my place anyway.
Jake:我得行
Jake: I have to.
Shure的女友:你把他赶走了
Violet: You drove him away.
Jake:拍照挺
Jake: Taking photos is pretty.
Jake:我觉得这张照片还行
Jake: I think this photo is okay.
Shure: 什么叫赶走
Shure: What do you mean drove away?
Jake:多拍几张应该就BIOS
Jake: Take a few more and it should be good.
Shure的女友:你把他赶走了
Violet: You drove him away.
Shure: 不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Katrina: 不然他老坐我旁边
Katrina: Otherwise, he always sits next to me.
Shure: 再说再说
Shure: Let's talk about it later.
Katrina: 我看不到他们的摄像头
Katrina: I can't see their camera.
Nicous: 但是他的点已经不在于你们的行为了
Nicous: But the point is no longer about your actions.
Nicous: 是确实没关系
Nicous: It really doesn't matter.
Jake:没关系这个回头我们分析一下
Jake: It doesn't matter, we'll analyze it later.
Jake:我们找个人专门分析时段
Jake: We'll find someone to analyze the time slots.
Shure的女友:你是昨天没有昨天没有
Violet: You didn't have it yesterday.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Shure的女友:不代表前天没有
Violet: That doesn't mean it wasn't there the day before yesterday.
Jake:我们一共有15个摄像头跟8个第一视角
Jake: We have a total of 15 cameras and 8 first-person views.
Shure: 大前天
Shure: The day before the day before yesterday.
Shure的女友:大前天
Violet: The day before the day before yesterday.
Alice:来吧这是一只
Alice: Come on, here's one.
Shure的女友:对大前天
Violet: Yeah, the day before the day before yesterday.
Shure的女友:修跟我打视频电话嘛
Violet: Shure video called me.
Shure的女友:然后视频电话呀
Violet: And then video call.
Shure的女友:哎你在说什么
Violet: Hey, what are you talking about?
Jake:什么什么
Jake: What, what?
Shure的女友:对然后然后然后你不是在那跟他讲
Violet: Yeah, and then you were talking to him.
Shure的女友:就是啊OK
Violet: Like, OK.
Shure的女友:就是一个什么北欧的男生
Violet: It was some Nordic guy.
Shure: 那那是另一个
Shure: That was someone else.
Shure的女友:我知道是另一个
Violet: I know it was someone else.
Alice:我确实不美
Alice: I really don't think I'm pretty.
Shure的女友:我现在知道了
Shure's GF: Now I know.
Shure的女友:然后当时我来的时候
Shure's GF: And then when I first came,
Katrina: 我以为是我是捂得高高的
Katrina: I thought I was covered pretty well.
Jake:那确实
Jake: That's true.
Katrina: 我感觉你耳朵这样
Katrina: I feel like your ears were like this.
Shure的女友:然后然后当时看到
Shure's GF: And then, at that time,
Shure的女友:我以为是你把他约出来了
Shure's GF: I thought you asked him out.
Shure的女友:因为那个不敢约
Shure's GF: Because he didn't dare.
Nicous: 有胆小鬼
Nicous: Such a coward.
Shure的女友:奥然哈哈
Shure's GF: Oh, right, haha.
Jake:为啥
Jake: Why?
Shure: 你约他一顿饭呢
Shure: You invited him to a meal.
Shure的女友:约出来了
Shure's GF: Asked him out.
Shure的女友:然后你能不能别倒了喝两口
Shure's GF: Can you stop and have a sip?
Shure: 能不能别倒了喝两口姐
Shure: Can you stop and have a sip, sis?
Jack: 哦靠 cp cp
Jack: Oh my, CP, CP.
Katrina: 我当时真感觉
Katrina: I really felt at that time,
Nicous: 你越不能把这张照片发给他
Nicous: You shouldn't send this photo to him.
Nicous: 你要把你们俩照片发给他
Nicous: You should send the photo of you two.
Jake:来瞧一瞧瞧一瞧
Jake: Come on, take a look.
Nicous: 你把第二张照片发给他他就赢麻了
Nicous: If you send the second photo, he's gonna win big.
Shure的女友:什么结婚照
Shure's GF: What, a wedding photo?
刘婷:去里面挠了一下喉咙
Liu Ting: Scratched my throat inside.
Nicous: 你就给爽到了到
Nicous: You'll enjoy it a lot.
嘉宾:第二张照片发给这男的
Guest: Send the second photo to this guy.
嘉宾:他直接作壁纸了
Guest: He'll use it as wallpaper immediately.
男嘉宾:对他他他直接就就就
Male Guest: Yeah, he, he, he will just...
男嘉宾:颅内高潮颅内高潮
Male Guest: Brain orgasm, brain orgasm.
Shure的女友:我我真的感觉
Shure's GF: I really felt
Shure的女友:就是当时看到你们俩的状态
Shure's GF: at that time seeing the state of you two,
Shure的女友:我以为他是那个人
Shure's GF: I thought he was that person.
Shure的女友:然后我说呃OK
Shure's GF: Then I said, uh OK.
Shure的女友:可能这个人
Shure's GF: Maybe this person...
Katrina: 可是我对他没有那种很主动的行为
Katrina: But I didn't show much initiative towards him.
男嘉宾:来来来
Male Guest: Come on, come on.
Katrina: 我都没跟他说什么话呀
Katrina: I didn't say much to him.
Jake:内部数据
Jake: Internal data.
Jack: 分析一下
Jack: Let's analyze it.
女嘉宾:我觉得挺正常的
Female Guest: I think it's quite normal.
Katrina: 因为我觉得因为我觉得尴尬了
Katrina: Because I feel, because I feel awkward.
女嘉宾:我觉得挺正常的
Female Guest: I think it's quite normal.
Jack: 不知道我们这属于这一段
Jack: I don't know if we belong in this segment.
Jack: 属于因号此类吧
Jack: Maybe it's classified as this type.
男嘉宾:可能正常的就是这个图片组
Male Guest: Maybe what's normal is this picture group.
Shure的女友:无所谓
Shure's GF: Doesn't matter.
女嘉宾:平等的撞死所有人
Female Guest: Equality crashes everyone.
Shure的女友:就是在这几天就是享受就好了
Shure's GF: Just enjoy these days.
男嘉宾:这个系列
Male Guest: This series.
Jack: 这个这个主要得有系列
Jack: This, this mainly needs a series.
Shure的女友:无所谓
Shure's GF: Doesn't matter.
男嘉宾:我到时候可以用这个数据集多多来
Male Guest: I can use this dataset more often later.
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry.
Jack: 多多多来一次
Jack: Use it more, more, more often.
Katrina: 居然是这样的
Katrina: It's actually like this.
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry.
Katrina: 居然是这样子
Katrina: It's actually like this.
Shure的女友:邀请你
Shure's GF: Invite you.
男嘉宾:没有没有你谋生哦
Male Guest: No, no, you make a living.
Katrina: 确实北欧男不来
Katrina: Indeed, Northern European men don't come.
Shure的女友:对就是你活动娱乐活动就是怎么讲
Shure's GF: Yes, your entertainment activities, how to say...
Katrina: 是北欧男不喜欢然后
Katrina: Northern European men don't like it, and then...
Shure的女友:你这种
Shure's GF: This kind of thing...
男嘉宾:没有没有特别多
Male Guest: Not particularly many.
Shure的女友:我来我我来北京
Shure's GF: I came, I came to Beijing.
Jake:很多啦
Jake: A lot.
Shure的女友:我参加一个活动
Shure's GF: I attended an event.
Shure的女友:然后最后一天那个阿弗伦party
Shure's GF: And the last day, the afternoon party.
Jake:特别多是啥意思
Jake: What does "particularly many" mean?
Jake:你这小地方
Jake: In this small place.
Jake:比这强劲的
Jake: Better than this.
Shure的女友:我要邀请一个朋友
Shure's GF: I want to invite a friend.
Jake:几张照片了
Jake: How many photos?
Shure的女友:然后我邀请了你
Shure's GF: And I invited you.
男嘉宾:还好
Male Guest: It's okay.
Shure的女友:然后你过来了
Shure's GF: And you came over.
Shure的女友:这件事情本身来讲
Shure's GF: This thing itself.
男嘉宾:数据
Male Guest: Data.
Jake:七八
Jake: Seven or eight.
Shure的女友:就是一个很暧昧的事情
Shure's GF: It's a very ambiguous thing.
男嘉宾:是你们得看那个摄像头里面的啊啊
Male Guest: You guys need to check the camera, ahh.
女嘉宾:这两个发给你
Female Guest: I'll send you these two.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Okay.
刘婷:你笑点很低呀
Liu Ting: You have a low laugh threshold.
女嘉宾:这两个还蛮好的嗯
Female Guest: These two are pretty good, huh.
Alice:是吗那别人怎么不这么好笑
Alice: Really? Then why don't others find it that funny?
Shure的女友:非常actually
Shure's GF: Very, actually.
女嘉宾:这个在搅搅的
Female Guest: This one's stirring around.
Katrina: CPU烧了
Katrina: The CPU burned out.
男嘉宾:因为因为因为只能邀
Male Guest: Because, because, because you can only invite...
男嘉宾:因为因为只能邀你只邀请到了一个
Male Guest: Because, because you can only invite, you only invited one person.
女嘉宾:搅搅哈
Female Guest: Stirring around, huh.
男嘉宾:你只邀请到了一个
Male Guest: You only invited one person.
Shure的女友:yeah just one对
Shure's GF: Yeah, just one, right.
男嘉宾:对你只邀请到一个这个是
Male Guest: Right, you only invited one person.
男嘉宾:你只邀请到一个
Male Guest: You only invited one person.
男嘉宾:这个事情就很就很tricky
Male Guest: This thing is just very tricky.
Shure: 而且你得回
Shure: And you have to go back.
男嘉宾:邀请的人家
Male Guest: Invite someone.
男嘉宾:你邀请不是人家问的你
Male Guest: You invite, it's not them asking you.
Shure的女友:对是你是你问他
Shure's GF: Right, it's you asking them.
Shure的女友:就是可能对你来讲
Shure's GF: Maybe for you...
Shure的女友:你筛选的选项就是啊在北京我认识
Shure's GF: The options you filter through are, in Beijing, I know...
Shure的女友:还可以很熟
Shure's GF: It's quite familiar.
Shure的女友:然后我可以邀请人
Shure's GF: And I can invite people.
Shure的女友:对他来说就是
Shure's GF: For him...
Shure的女友:对他来说就是哦他邀请我
Shure's GF: For him, it's like, oh, he invited me.
Shure的女友:只有一个我要邀请人
Shure's GF: Only one, I have to invite people.
Shure的女友:我邀请人家哇
Shure's GF: I invite people, wow.
Jack: 女孩子在国内的语境
Jack: Girls in the domestic context...
Jack: 女孩子主动邀请这种选择
Jack: Girls actively inviting, such a choice...
Nicous: 而且那个男生他就是在
Nicous: And that guy, he just...
Nicous: 他需要的是
Nicous: What he needs is...
Shure: 前所未有的数据集
Shure: An unprecedented dataset.
Katrina: 我北京我不待几天
Katrina: I'll only stay in Beijing for a few days.
Katrina: 然后别担心一起见
Katrina: Then don't worry, let's meet up.
女嘉宾:我在看他在割双眼皮的一个
Female Guest: I'm watching him getting double eyelid surgery.
Katrina: 见个面就不担心
Katrina: Just meet up, no worries.
Shure的女友:别担心掉人生了
Shure's GF: Don't worry, life's not over.
Jack: 他现在肯定已经在回去的路上想着
Jack: He's probably thinking about it on his way back right now.
女嘉宾:这是他在试验双眼皮
Female Guest: He's experimenting with double eyelids.
男嘉宾:到时候回武汉的时候
Male Guest: When he gets back to Wuhan.
Jake:他有时候是
Jake: Sometimes he...
男嘉宾:我一般去北京西站送
Male Guest: I usually go to Beijing West Station to send off.
女嘉宾:但是我看他这个封面区别还是蛮大的
Female Guest: But I see a big difference in his cover.
Jake: 点
Jake: Point.
男嘉宾:你也是这样的必是这样的
Male Guest: You are like this, must be like this.
Jake: 点
Jake: Point.
Nicous: 我也在规划五一去武汉
Nicous: I'm also planning to go to Wuhan for May Day.
Nicous: 就是在纠结
Nicous: Just hesitating.
Katrina: 他也邀请过我
Katrina: He invited me too.
Shure的女友:6666 stop
Shure's GF: 6666 stop.
Katrina: 一起去玩
Katrina: To go have fun together.
Jack: 卧槽一起出去玩你还要
Jack: What the heck, to go out together and you still...
Alice:弱智视频
Alice: Stupid video.
Katrina: 但是我当然是
Katrina: But of course, I...
Katrina: 到时候再说
Katrina: I'll decide later.
Nicous: 不是一起出去玩
Nicous: Not to go out together.
Alice:我也不知道是不是
Alice: I don't know if it is.
Nicous: 就是很明显很难邀请的
Nicous: It's just obviously hard to invite.
Alice:你看
Alice: Look.
Jake:这很难邀请的
Jake: It's hard to invite.
Jake:很难出口的邀请来
Jake: An invitation that's hard to extend.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
男嘉宾:而且得并没有得到一个你直接否定的
Male Guest: And you didn't get a direct rejection.
Jack: 怎么说呢
Jack: How to say...
Jack: 因为他要求你
Jack: Because he asks you.
女嘉宾:好牛啊
Female Guest: So cool.
Katrina: 因为我觉得拒绝很尴尬
Katrina: Because I think it's awkward to refuse.
Katrina: 就是大家是很好的朋友
Katrina: We're all good friends.
Jack: 男女生朋友单独一点
Jack: Friends of opposite genders alone.
Jack: 但感觉就是就是从那个他的视角
Jack: But it feels like, from his perspective...
Shure的女友:他可能从从女孩子视角来讲
Shure's GF: Maybe from a girl's perspective...
Shure的女友:不要担心任何事情
Shure's GF: Don't worry about anything.
Shure的女友:你给他吊就行了
Shure's GF: Just hang out with him.
Shure的女友:为什么男生有这个特征
Shure's GF: Why do guys have this trait?
Shure的女友:女生也可以有啊
Shure's GF: Girls can have it too.
Shure的女友:whatever
Shure's GF: Whatever.
Shure的女友:吊就行了我喜欢
Shure's GF: Just hang out with him, I like it.
Shure的女友:你开心就好
Shure's GF: As long as you're happy.
男嘉宾:就当天晚上
Male Guest: Just that night.
男嘉宾:这不是正常吗
Male Guest: Isn't that normal?
Jack: 当天就有这么好的吗
Jack: Was it that good on the same day?
Shure: 别我害怕
Shure: No, I'm scared.
Jack: 过夜啊对啊
Jack: Overnight, yeah.
Jack: 当天就到这份上了
Jack: It got to that point on the same day.
Shure: 要不我们三个
Shure: How about the three of us...
Shure: 不要不要
Shure: No, no.
Shure的女友:就是咱俩现在分手
Shure's GF: So we're breaking up now.
Shure的女友:我猜不来吧来斯宾
Shure's GF: I guess not, come on, let's...
Shure的女友:OK
Shure's GF: OK.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 哈哈哈这不是重点
Shure: Hahaha, that's not the point.
Jake:就预约了
Jake: Just made an appointment.
Jake:就是
Jake: That's it.
Katrina: 但是我肯定不会跟他单独去啊
Katrina: But there's no way I'd go alone with him.
Katrina: 那当时就是拒绝什么的
Katrina: So at that time, I just refused.
Katrina: 因为不好接受啊
Katrina: Because it was hard to accept.
Katrina: 我说我当时跟他去他真提出来这个
Katrina: I said, if I went with him and he really brought this up...
Jake:invitation就这个invitation
Jake: The invitation, just this invitation.
Jake:太BIOS
Jake: So BIOS.
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
Shure的女友:不是我在想我就好受欢迎
Shure: I was just thinking, I'm so popular.
Jake:今天又邀请来了
Jake: Got another invitation today.
Jake:不一样了给你说
Jake: It's different this time, let me tell you.
Shure: 你怎么每天就是照着镜子我好美
Shure: How do you look in the mirror every day and think, "I'm so beautiful"?
Shure: 然后晚上我好受欢迎
Shure: And then at night, "I'm so popular"?
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake:那
Jake: Well...
Shure的女友:别担心知道现在爱着你
Shure: Don't worry, you know you're loved now.
Shure: 至少现在
Shure: At least for now.
Shure: 今天 可以了
Shure: Today, that's enough.
Shure: 你这定位加的有点多
Shure: You've set your expectations a bit high.
Shure的女友:以后也是吧
Shure: It'll be the same in the future, right?
Shure: 好好看一下
Shure: Take a good look.
Jake:你眼镜呢
Jake: Where are your glasses?
Katrina: 我眼睛在充电
Katrina: My eyes are recharging.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Katrina: 刚刚一直在充充电宝
Katrina: Just been charging my power bank.
Katrina: 但是它还是显示没电
Katrina: But it's still showing no battery.
Jake:什么眼镜
Jake: What glasses?
Jake:就是什么充电宝
Jake: What kind of power bank?
Jake:就这种吗
Jake: Like this one?
Shure: 可能没电了这个
Shure: Maybe this one is out of battery.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:没关系这边有足够的数据
Jake: It's fine, we have enough data here.
Jack: 今天今天你们
Jack: Today, today you guys...
Jack: 今天你们有非常多份的
Jack: Today you guys have a lot of...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jack: 这个今天你们有非常多份的照片
Jack: You have a lot of photos today.
Shure: 妈妈带娃是吧
Shure: Moms with kids, right?
Shure的女友:妈妈带娃是的
Shure's GF: Moms with kids, yes.
Jake:是的希望他以后能用到这个数据集
Jake: Yes, hope they can use this data in the future.
男嘉宾:哎你你这个数据题研究一下
Male Guest: Hey, you, you study this data problem.
Shure的女友:我有点想跟他加个微信
Shure's GF: I kind of want to add him on WeChat.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure的女友:所以你跟他加可不可以
Shure's GF: So, can you add him?
男嘉宾:这段我们没事这段我们可以搞成
Male Guest: This part, we can handle this part.
Shure: 谁啊
Shure: Who?
Shure的女友:sorry please
Shure's GF: Sorry, please.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
男嘉宾:这这段可以
Male Guest: This part is okay.
Shure: 摄摄摄影师
Shure: Photographer.
Jake:知道
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 我们加个微信
Shure: Let's add on WeChat.
Shure: 后期后期
Shure: Later, later.
Shure: 这个照片对
Shure: These photos, yes.
Shure的女友:哎哎哎毕业照是不是想我拍
Shure's GF: Hey, hey, hey, do you want me to take your graduation photos?
Shure: 一百三百几来着
Shure: One hundred, three hundred something?
Shure的女友:no
Shure's GF: No.
Shure: 哎呀稍等
Shure: Oh, wait a minute.
Shure: 真真
Shure: Really.
Shure的女友:给你打个折好吧
Shure's GF: I'll give you a discount, okay?
Nicous: 他不一定有时间过来
Nicous: He might not have time to come over.
Shure的女友:打折好吗
Shure's GF: Discount, okay?
Shure的女友:给你们打折
Shure's GF: I'll give you guys a discount.
Shure的女友:啊我天
Shure's GF: Oh my god.
Shure的女友:就修硕我朋友的话
Shure's GF: If Shure is my friend.
Shure的女友:我可能直接就不要钱了
Shure's GF: I might not charge at all.
Katrina: 他刚刚在这的时候还抱了我们
Katrina: He just hugged us when he was here.
Jack: 在这都抱你
Jack: Hugged you here?
Katrina: 他说要走了
Katrina: He said he was leaving.
Katrina: 他说我们
Katrina: He said we...
Nicous: 不是真的抱了
Nicous: Did he really hug you?
Katrina: 下一面什么时候再见就会抱你
Katrina: Next time we meet, he will hug you.
Jack: 不是他怎么抱的
Jack: How did he hug you?
Shure的女友:呃我拿一下我拿一下
Shure: Uh, let me take it, let me take it.
女嘉宾:软件工程就可能是写扎瓦的哦
Female Guest: Software engineering might involve writing Java, you know.
Shure的女友:我现在有点看不清哇那个男女
Shure: I can't really see clearly now, the guys and gals.
Jack: 国内男女收
Jack: Guys and gals back home.
Katrina: 因为他每次都这样
Katrina: Because he's always like this.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
男嘉宾:他每次都爽了
Male Guest: He always enjoys it.
Shure的女友:你今天喝成这个样子
Shure: You drank so much today.
Nicous: 你你是会总结的
Nicous: You, you are good at summarizing.
Shure的女友:明天还在吗
Shure: Will you be here tomorrow?
男嘉宾:但但绝对不会放你过来
Male Guest: But, but they definitely won't let you come over.
Shure的女友:公司大概要两个半小时啊
Shure: The company takes about two and a half hours.
Jake:不是 是什么同学
Jake: No, what classmate?
Shure的女友:就是石砖
Shure: Just bricks.
Jake:什么同学
Jake: What classmate?
Lucia:对我老家就是西安的
Lucia: Yes, my hometown is Xi'an.
Jake:什么关系
Jake: What relationship?
Katrina: 但是我会经常在新疆那边
Katrina: But I often go to Xinjiang.
Shure的女友:嗯no no no
Shure: Hmm, no no no.
Katrina: 那时候认识的
Katrina: We met at that time.
Shure的女友:一转10转13是
Shure: A turn, 10 turns, 13 is...
女嘉宾:嗯挺好的
Female Guest: Hmm, quite good.
Nicous: 宝研认识了网友
Nicous: Baoyan met an online friend.
Jack: 国内男女生朋友
Jack: Guys and gals friends back home.
女嘉宾:我老我老家是湖北的
Female Guest: My hometown is Hubei.
Jake:保研认识
Jake: Baoyan met.
Jake:什么意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Jack: 线下
Jack: Offline.
Jake:他是什么学阶
Jake: What level student is he?
Katrina: 就是就在5月份的时候小红书认识
Katrina: Just in May, we met on Xiaohongshu.
Katrina: 然后就保研搭子
Katrina: Then, Baoyan partner.
Katrina: 然后那个时候都发了一些链接
Katrina: At that time, we shared some links.
女嘉宾:所以你就是一直也在湖北
Female Guest: So you've always been in Hubei.
Katrina: 开营链接
Katrina: Opening camp link
Katrina: 然后大家互通一些消息
Katrina: Then everyone can exchange some information
女嘉宾:对我从高考之前就在湖北
Female Guest: Yes, I've been in Hubei since before the college entrance exam
Katrina: 然后呢后来9月份也没说什么
Katrina: And then, in September, he didn't say much
女嘉宾:然后来北京
Female Guest: Then I came to Beijing
Katrina: 然后11月份的时候
Katrina: And in November
Katrina: 他来武汉找我玩了一趟
Katrina: He came to Wuhan to hang out with me
Katrina: 以后就开始每天发消息
Katrina: After that, we started messaging every day
Jake:哦那也那确实那
Jake: Oh, well that's, that indeed is
Katrina: 然后就到现在都不职业到
Katrina: And since then, we haven't been professional
Jake:那这个时间线很标准啊
Jake: The timeline is pretty standard
Jake:很很标准
Jake: Very, very standard
Jack: 比较少因为我还是更爱拍朋友
Jack: It's less because I prefer filming friends
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
男嘉宾:你们俩聊天记录什么频率
Male Guest: How often do you guys chat?
男嘉宾:看聊天记录日期嗯
Male Guest: Check the chat history dates, huh
Jake:就走上正轨了
Jake: It's on track now
男嘉宾:没怎么说话
Male Guest: Didn't talk much
Jake:就是哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Just, hahaha
男嘉宾:没怎么说话
Male Guest: Didn't talk much
男嘉宾:但是天天在聊
Male Guest: But chatting every day
Nicous: 你不回一下
Nicous: Aren't you going to reply?
Katrina: 回了我说我说
Katrina: I replied, I said, I said
Jake:来看一看
Jake: Take a look
男嘉宾:不是你看那个
Male Guest: No, look at that
Jake:啊就是哎这个错过的一个小影片
Jake: Ah, it's like, hey, this is a missed little video
男嘉宾:看看那个日记
Male Guest: Check that diary
Jack: 你看日记是不是每天都对
Jack: You see the diary, it's every day right
Jack: 你可以那个拿那个
Jack: You can use that
Jack: 哈哈行了行了行了
Jack: Haha, alright, alright, alright
男嘉宾:建议这还说什么
Male Guest: Suggest this, what else to say
男嘉宾:建议立刻按C1处理
Male Guest: Suggest to handle it immediately with C1
男嘉宾:你看他老上海都是你
Male Guest: Look, in old Shanghai, it's all about you
Nicous: 知道他自我介绍的时候说什么吗
Nicous: Do you know what he said during his self-introduction?
Nicous: 他说我叫杜叉叉AK
Nicous: He said, my name is Du XX AK
Nicous: 李宇轩的小刘宇轩的小跟班
Nicous: Liu Yuxuan's little follower
Nicous: 卧槽这还不明显吗
Nicous: Damn, isn't that obvious?
Jack: 我觉得这个倒没事
Jack: I think that's fine
Jake:但是这个没有对应上画面
Jake: But this doesn't match the footage
Jack: 但这个但这个东西已经就是
Jack: But this, but this thing is already
Jake:因为实在是剪不过来了
Jake: Because there's just too much to edit.
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
男嘉宾:但是就看
Male Guest: But just look.
Shure的女友:调人像还是调整个构图
Shure's GF: Adjust the portrait or the composition.
Jake:毕竟是
Jake: After all...
Jake:毕竟是presentation之前的一个小时嘛
Jake: After all, it's just an hour before the presentation.
Jack: 都会有吧
Jack: It happens, right?
Jack: 我给你看一些
Jack: Let me show you some.
男嘉宾:不是这个
Male Guest: Not this one.
Jake:对吧you know
Jake: Right, you know.
男嘉宾:那你都主动给他分享啊
Male Guest: You actively share with him?
Jake:就是被抓了一下
Jake: I just got caught.
Katrina: 你说这种人会被抓到
Katrina: You said people like that would get caught.
Nicous: 会哎呀
Nicous: They would, oh man.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Jack: 说实话啊他说话真的好多啊
Jack: Honestly, he talks so much.
Jake: GBD写的
Jake: GBD wrote it.
Jake:GPT写的
Jake: GPT wrote it.
Jake:然后搜搜AI谱的曲
Jake: Then searched for AI to compose the music.
男嘉宾:我就看你最近一直非常害怕
Male Guest: I've noticed you've been really scared lately.
Shure的女友:但我感觉
Shure's GF: But I feel...
男嘉宾:还发自拍哎呀
Male Guest: Still posting selfies, oh man.
男嘉宾:因为他们其中一方是很凶的
Male Guest: Because one of them is very fierce.
男嘉宾:我看看我一当当
Male Guest: Let me see, just a sec.
Katrina: 没有我们俩后来
Katrina: No, we later...
男嘉宾:没有办法
Male Guest: No way.
男嘉宾:哦他没看着
Male Guest: Oh, he didn't see it.
男嘉宾:其实怎么讲
Male Guest: Actually, how to say...
Shure的女友:很多时候就是大家去找男生的话
Shure's GF: Often, when everyone looks for guys...
Shure的女友:我一般找的都是工作上的
Shure's GF: I usually look for work-related matters.
Katrina: 找的基本就是就是
Katrina: Basically, it's just...
Tasha:你有看过这段影像吗
Tasha: Have you seen this footage?
Shure的女友:男社会更在意构图而不是
Shure's GF: Men care more about composition than...
Shure的女友:是他的状态
Shure's GF: Their state.
Nicous: 你也给他发自拍
Nicous: You also send him selfies?
Lucia:我要我要确保一下
Lucia: I need to make sure.
Katrina: 当然啊
Katrina: Of course.
Shure的女友:所以可能就是肠胃比较小
Shure's GF: So maybe he has a small stomach.
Nicous: 没有吃我的
Nicous: He didn't eat mine.
男嘉宾:我不会给他发自拍
Male Guest: I wouldn't send him selfies.
男嘉宾:他也没有给我发自拍
Male Guest: He didn't even send me a selfie.
Shure的女友:肠胃软件也是CS
Shure: The digestive software is also CS.
Shure的女友:还是那个说CS挺想家的
Shure: It's still the one who says CS feels homesick.
Shure的女友:对反正你需要调
Shure: Yeah, anyway, you need to adjust.
Shure的女友:然后对你做色调什么
Shure: And then adjust the color tone for you or something.
Shure的女友:然后那个香香皂稍微磨磨皮
Shure: And then slightly smooth the skin with some fragrant soap.
Shure的女友:什么修修那种什么给大家
Shure: What kind of editing, giving everyone...
男嘉宾:什么修修那种什么给大家
Male Guest: What kind of editing, giving everyone...
Katrina: 他参加了蛮多夏令营
Katrina: He attended quite a few summer camps.
Shure的女友:那个里地没他丰富
Shure: Not as rich as him in that area.
Shure的女友:所以加他去一些商太门
Shure: So take him to some business gates.
Shure的女友:因为来了商太门
Shure: Because he came to the business gates.
Shure的女友:我觉得北京商太门
Shure: I think Beijing business gates...
Katrina: 但是没有那么喜欢的感觉
Katrina: But didn't like it that much.
男嘉宾:就是女生对一个男生
Male Guest: It's just a girl towards a guy...
Jake:妙
Jake: Wonderful.
Lucia:特别好特别好
Lucia: Really good, really good.
Jake:妙 妙啊
Jake: Wonderful, wonderful.
男嘉宾:我一般都秒
Male Guest: I usually do it instantly.
Shure的女友:但其实是有歧视
Shure: But actually, there's discrimination.
Shure的女友:恋大家会喜欢找女生
Shure: People tend to prefer finding girls.
男嘉宾:那肯定了
Male Guest: Definitely.
男嘉宾:女孩子呢
Male Guest: Girls, you know.
男嘉宾:现在这
Male Guest: Now this...
Shure的女友:大家会觉得哦OK
Shure: People will think, oh OK.
Shure的女友:你去找女生
Shure: You go find girls.
Shure的女友:你整个人呢
Shure: Your whole self...
Jack: 就你对对对
Jack: Yeah, you, right, right.
男嘉宾:而且这年头确实也是有那个
Male Guest: And these days, there really is that...
男嘉宾:对很多这个会有这种需求
Male Guest: Many have that kind of need.
男嘉宾:你首先他肯定
Male Guest: First, he definitely...
男嘉宾:他问你形象
Male Guest: He asks about your image.
男嘉宾:你为什么一直
Male Guest: Why are you always...
Shure的女友:你背一下
Shure: You recite it.
Shure的女友:我不想我不想这这块被记录下来
Shure: I don't want, I don't want this part recorded.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Katrina: 大家都没有考虑这是什么啊
Katrina: No one considered what this is, huh?
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:充电宝加油
Jake: Power bank, go for it!
Jake:哈哈哈哈给我录
Jake: Hahaha, record this for me.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:走要不戴
Jake: Let's go, or should we wear it?
Jake:要不戴上吧要不戴上吧
Jake: Or should we wear it? Let's wear it.
刘婷:下回实在不行整个有兜的
Liu Ting: Next time, just get something with pockets.
Shure的女友:就不可能喜欢纯哥们
Shure's GF: It's impossible to like just buddies.
男嘉宾:就是有没有那种能喜欢一点
Male Guest: Isn't there someone you could like a little?
男嘉宾:坏怎么都是哥们
Male Guest: Why are they all just buddies?
男嘉宾:那不坏那不坏
Male Guest: That's not bad, not bad at all.
Shure的女友:没有一点关系
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter at all.
Katrina: 我要我要
Katrina: I want to, I want to.
Katrina: 喜欢的话我第一眼喜欢就是喜欢
Katrina: If I like someone at first sight, I just like them.
Nicous: 为什么没带出
Nicous: Why didn't you bring it out?
男嘉宾:那你下次就告诉他你下次就告诉他
Male Guest: Then just tell him next time, just tell him.
男嘉宾:就说你就说
Male Guest: Just say, just say.
男嘉宾:我我我喜欢我喜欢的人
Male Guest: I, I, I like the person I like.
Shure: 他一直在放
Shure: He's been playing it all along.
Shure: 他那个普通朋友是吗
Shure: That regular friend, right?
Shure: 那个全民k歌那软件
Shure: That app, the Karaoke for All.
Jack: 有人会喜欢这种所谓的胶片风
Jack: Some people like that so-called film style.
Shure的女友:胶片感
Shure's GF: Film vibe.
Shure的女友:但是你拍胶片要爱的毕竟胶片
Shure's GF: But if you shoot film, you gotta love it because it's film.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure的女友:我们我们前几天去了趟河北
Shure's GF: We, we went to Hebei a few days ago.
Shure的女友:然后我带了一个一次性的胶片
Shure's GF: And I brought a disposable film camera.
Shure的女友:就整个胶片拍出来
Shure's GF: Shot the whole thing on film.
Shure的女友:感觉除了被手指挡到的那部分
Shure's GF: Except for the parts covered by fingers.
Shure的女友:所有照片都是原图指出的
Shure's GF: All the photos came out as the originals.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 咱也开车
Jake: Let's drive too.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia:哎哎
Lucia: Hey, hey.
Shure: 这个灯到点会自己灭
Shure: This light will turn off by itself at a certain time.
Lucia:怎么突然断电了
Lucia: Why did the power suddenly go out?
Lucia:才九点半哎
Lucia: It's only 9:30.
Lucia:好过份 至少也要十一点断电吧
Lucia: So unfair, at least cut the power at 11.
Alice:你在瞎录啥呢
Alice: What are you randomly recording?
女嘉宾:可是我发现啊
Female Guest: But I found out...
Shure: 没事我不录不录 唉
Shure: It's okay, I'm not recording, not recording. Sigh.
Shure的女友:我们要讲些商业机密
Shure's GF: We need to discuss some business secrets.
Shure的女友:我都拉他进工作室了
Shure's GF: I've already brought him into the studio.
男嘉宾:然后你对好朋友的这种相处方式
Male Guest: And how do you get along with your good friends?
Nicous: 也是不希望好朋友难受对吧
Nicous: You don't want your good friends to feel uncomfortable, right?
Nicous: 不需要他觉得
Nicous: No need for him to feel that way.
Katrina: 因为我觉得不礼貌
Katrina: Because I think it's impolite.
Katrina: 人家发那么多红包
Katrina: They send so many red packets.
Nicous: 但是这种行为
Nicous: But this kind of behavior...
男嘉宾:可能男生就觉得你也喜欢他
Male Guest: Maybe guys think you like them too.
Shure的女友:我在北京搞摄影的唯一目的
Shure's GF: My only purpose in doing photography in Beijing...
Shure的女友:哎 宝贝
Shure's GF: Hey baby...
Shure: 你快把我脖子
Shure: Quickly, my neck...
Shure的女友:交钱 给你拍了多少照片
Shure's GF: Pay up, how many photos have I taken for you?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure的女友:好好好
Shure's GF: Okay, okay.
Shure: 回家带你多吃吃点好的好吧
Shure: I'll take you home and get you something good to eat, okay?
Jake:7台相机
Jake: Seven cameras.
Jake:回头那个网页专门给你整一份
Jake: I'll make a special webpage for you later.
Jake:那个拍位置的
Jake: The one for taking positions.
Jake: 对 那段啊
Jake: Yes, that part.
Jake:啊剪出来
Jake: Edit it out.
Jake:他怎么了
Jake: What's wrong with him?
Nicous: 他老让我反思
Nicous: He keeps making me reflect.
Katrina: 所以我就觉得这些男生的这些行为
Katrina: So I think these guys' behaviors...
Katrina: 可能就是他顺手分享的什么的
Katrina: Maybe it's just something they casually share.
Katrina: 然后就不要自己不要
Katrina: And don't think too much about it yourself.
Katrina: 觉得自己不要自作多情
Katrina: Don't overthink it.
Katrina: 为什么要发啊
Katrina: Why send it?
男嘉宾:不是我给男生发
Male Guest: It's not like I'm sending it to guys.
男嘉宾:对男生会发
Male Guest: Yes, some guys will send it.
男嘉宾:就每个人不一样
Male Guest: Everyone is different.
男嘉宾:就是每个人那个艺人的方向不一样
Male Guest: Each artist has a different direction.
Alice:这个我是不是也很亮
Alice: Am I shining too much?
男嘉宾:这不好拍
Male Guest: This is hard to shoot.
男嘉宾:挺好瞎处置
Male Guest: It's fine, just handle it.
男嘉宾:你就等他说吧
Male Guest: Just wait for him to speak.
男嘉宾:就按照现在
Male Guest: Just follow the current...
Nicous: 主要还是长太漂亮了
Nicous: Mainly because she's too beautiful.
女嘉宾:但我最近就跟他们聊了
Female Guest: But recently I've been talking to them...
Nicous: 没事今天我给他搭回去啊
Nicous: It's fine, I'll give him a ride back today.
Katrina: 反正我是觉得就是来北京
Katrina: Anyway, I just feel like coming to Beijing...
Nicous: 今天给他搭回去
Nicous: I'll give him a ride back today.
Nicous: 回到100%的草药版
Nicous: Back to the 100% herbal version.
Jake:你这抗遗忘曲线挺挺挺棒的
Jake: Your curve of forgetting resistance is pretty impressive.
Jake:我靠 越来越稳
Jake: Wow, you're getting steadier and steadier.
Jake:哈哈哈抗遗忘曲线你知道吧
Jake: Hahaha, you know about the forgetting resistance curve, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 人民教师了
Shure: A people's teacher.
Shure: 什么钱什么钱啊
Shure: What money, what money?
Shure: 刮刮吧
Shure: Scratch it.
Shure: 你看我能能刮多长就全转过去好不好
Shure: Let me see how long I can scratch it, and I'll turn it all over, alright?
Shure: 修硕的路费没了
Shure: Shure's travel expenses are gone.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 你还想刮我什么
Shure: What else do you want to scratch from me?
Shure: 嗯回家还能让你花钱
Shure: Hmm, going home can still make you spend money.
Shure的女友:不是我真觉得在家里住有点不好
Shure's GF: No, I really think living at home is a bit bad.
Shure的女友:能在外面住的话真的好困
Shure's GF: If you can live outside, it's really exhausting.
Katrina: 但是那个
Katrina: But that...
Shure: 我妈感觉就是
Shure: My mom feels that...
Shure: 让你在外面住就是感觉
Shure: Letting you live outside feels like...
Shure: 没有
Shure: There's no...
Shure的女友:没有太好客
Shure's GF: Not very hospitable.
Shure: 对对对没有家那种感觉
Shure: Yeah, yeah, it doesn't have that home feeling.
男嘉宾:觉得你好看不
Male Guest: Do you think you're good-looking?
Shure的女友:因为觉得你好看
Shure's GF: Because they think you're good-looking.
Shure的女友:对觉得你好看
Shure's GF: Right, they think you're good-looking.
Shure: 谢彬竹这个
Shure: Xie Binzhu, this...
Shure: 这这个话说的
Shure: This, this remark...
Shure: 他谁看你朋友圈谁不知道
Shure: Whoever looks at your social media wouldn't know.
Shure的女友:你现在觉得哦OK
Shure's GF: Do you feel okay now?
Shure的女友:哪个男生不喜欢我
Shure's GF: Which guy doesn't like me?
Shure的女友:你可能就是陷入了一些南宁的视角
Shure's GF: You might just be trapped in some Nanning perspective.
Shure的女友:但是你无所谓怎么样
Shure's GF: But it doesn't matter anyway.
Nicous: 确实 我赞成
Nicous: Exactly, I agree.
Nicous: 有没有可能有没有可能
Nicous: Is it possible, is it possible...
Shure的女友:就当OK我我是最好看的一个
Shure's GF: Just think, okay, I'm the best-looking one.
Shure的女友:无所谓他们不喜欢我就是他们
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter, if they don't like me, that's on them.
Nicous: 有没有可能他
Nicous: Is it possible that he...
Shure的女友:他们他们眼睛有问题
Shure's GF: Their eyes have problems.
Shure的女友:无所谓我是这么
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter, I am like this.
Nicous: 有没有可能
Nicous: Is it possible...
Nicous: 有没有很好的啊
Nicous: ...that it's really good?
Nicous: 就是因为喜欢你
Nicous: Just because he likes you...
Nicous: 真的喜欢你的
Nicous: ...he really likes you.
Tasha:不知道他呀
Tasha: I don't know about him.
Nicous: 这不很正常吗
Nicous: Isn't that normal?
Katrina: 我我对我自己
Katrina: I, I to myself...
Katrina: 就是我不会容貌就是我不要应该喜欢
Katrina: ...I won't tolerate my looks. I shouldn't like...
Shure的女友:不要对你自己这样
Shure's GF: Don't be like that to yourself.
Katrina: 但是我
Katrina: But I...
Shure的女友:你对你自己
Shure's GF: You to yourself...
Tasha:这不是放屁吗
Tasha: Isn't this nonsense?
Shure的女友:你对你自己整个人感觉就是啊OK
Shure's GF: You to yourself, the whole feeling is... okay...
Shure的女友:整个世界都不喜欢我的人
Shure's GF: ...like the whole world doesn't like me.
Jack: 坏了开始开始开始
Jack: Oh no, it's starting, starting, starting.
Nicous: 这个指导
Nicous: This guide...
Katrina: 因为我很害怕
Katrina: Because I'm very scared.
男嘉宾:而且你生日都生日
Male Guest: And your birthday...
男嘉宾:都不用管人家喜不喜欢你
Male Guest: ...you don't have to care if others like you or not.
男嘉宾:跟你有什么关系呢
Male Guest: What does it have to do with you?
Jack: 对啊
Jack: Exactly.
Shure的女友:是啊
Shure's GF: Yes.
Katrina: 所以今天我对
Katrina: So today, I...
Nicous: 所以他就是喜欢你
Nicous: So he just likes you.
Shure的女友:他他喜欢就OK啦
Shure's GF: If he likes you, then it's okay.
Shure的女友:就是你你你
Shure's GF: It's just that you, you, you...
Katrina: 但是当我就是遇到了他喜欢我的时候
Katrina: But when I meet someone who likes me...
Nicous: 我就会考虑他为什么
Nicous: I start to wonder why...
Shure的女友:你喜欢他也无所谓
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter if you like him.
Shure的女友:他喜欢你也无所谓
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter if he likes you.
Shure的女友:就是你做你自己就好了
Shure's GF: Just be yourself.
Shure的女友:他喜不喜欢你就他现在
Shure's GF: Whether he likes you or not, right now...
Nicous: 他现在主要点
Nicous: His main point is...
Shure的女友:你不要内耗
Shure's GF: Don't overthink it.
Nicous: 他的点在于为什么
Nicous: His point is why...
Katrina: 为什么喜欢我
Katrina: Why does he like me?
Nicous: 他的点就在于为什么我们俩在群里
Nicous: His point is why when we chat in the group...
Nicous: 为什么一聊天
Nicous: ...why when we talk...
Shure的女友:你多有趣你足够好看
Shure's GF: You're interesting and good-looking enough.
Shure的女友:这还不是一个人喜欢的吗
Shure's GF: Isn't this something everyone likes?
Nicous: 黑点在就是看你朋友圈
Nicous: The black spot is just looking at your Moments.
Nicous: 朋友圈有多啊
Nicous: You have so many Moments.
Nicous: 放那么多
Nicous: Posting so much.
Nicous: 人家一晚上看完直接看
Nicous: People can watch them all in one night.
Nicous: 卧槽我
Nicous: Damn, I...
Shure的女友:Don't worry so you know why
Shure's GF: Don't worry, so you know why...
Shure的女友:是不是喜欢
Shure's GF: ...they like you, right?
Katrina: 这么这么容易就喜欢一个
Katrina: How can someone like another person so easily?
Shure的女友:even by shows
Shure's GF: ...even through shows.
Jake:好收工了收工了
Jake: Alright, wrap it up, wrap it up.
Jake:收工
Jake: Wrap it up.
Jake:不录了就就雨萱录一下吧
Jake: No more recording, just let Rain record.
Shure的女友:其实其实我也不知道为什么
Shure's GF: Actually, I don't really know why either.
Jake:哈收工了收工了
Jake: Haha, it's a wrap, it's a wrap.
Katrina: 因为我觉得
Katrina: Because I think...
Katrina: 因为我觉得人还是要相处的
Katrina: Because I think people need to get along.
Katrina: 觉得他是1月份的人
Katrina: I think he's a January person.
Katrina: 所以我就想了解
Katrina: So I want to get to know him.
Jake:好嘞关掉关掉关掉你关掉
Jake: Alright, turn it off, turn it off, you turn it off.
Shure的女友:哎sorry
Shure's GF: Oh, sorry.
Nicous: 我我给你讲一个事情
Nicous: Let me tell you something.
Nicous: 我给你讲一个
Nicous: Let me tell you...
Jake:complete
Jake: Complete.